I just had a question as to what you
guys see as a minimalist business
I've been running a catering / farmers
market for the past farmers market booth
for the past three years and I'm
wondering what you guys think about
expansion and taking on that to expand a
business that you are very passionate
about
I am also passionate about other things
outside of life outside of the
restaurant life though this is a good
thing to be flexible and travel as well
without a commitment of a brick and
mortar but to make a living from this
absolute work part-time and do the food
booth apartment as well it's not
something that can sustain us for a long
period of time without love love it you
know I think that johnny is doing
something important here and he's
realizing something more he's asking
some good questions here and I'll say
bravo for starting your own business and
not trying to take the giant leap of
starting a well I need I must do this
brick and mortar thing right away it's
not to say that that's the wrong thing
to do Ryan and I actually own a coffee
shop or were part owners of a coffee
shop down the st. Petersburg Florida
it's a long story but and it is a
minimalist business for sure and the
aesthetic is minimalist but also the way
that we run it is minimalist so he
Johnny's asking how do I run a
minimalist business it kind of depends
what you what you mean but do you mean
like aesthetic minimalism or in his case
I think he's meaning like the the
financial side of things now for me he
talked about the being passionate about
this business and I think that debt can
totally kill your passion oh yeah and it
limits your freedom too because if you
go all right we took on this debt well
actually I'd love to do this other thing
or like maybe I'd like some free time or
maybe want to have kids well it can't do
that we owe three hundred and fifty
thousand dollars to the bank for this
restaurant or this storefront and you
become indebted to a particular
lifestyle or work now I have to work 80
hours a week right I have to do this as
opposed to where you're at right now
johnny is I get to do this I get to do
the caterer I get to do the farmers
market so if I'm defining a
minimalist business for me three things
stand out I think debt can be maybe the
fourth thing here you strive to be
debt-free I'm not saying it's impossible
to run a minimalist business with with
debt it just makes it a bit more
difficult Ryan and I don't do debt at
all and our personal life or in our
business life but I could see there are
some scenarios where you might take on
you know you're buying a building or
something yes I will always stand by
there is no such thing as good debt I
mean it's it's funny because what we say
this all the time and people will like
send this is really long email like well
you know it's basically if you have a
lot of money like they'll get the
example of Mark Zuckerberg who bought a
you know fifty million dollar house and
put it on a loan because you had a 3%
interest rate but he can collect you
know 7% year-over-year on average with
the stock market it's like yes okay if
you have millions and millions of
dollars maybe in that scenario might be
smarter to take out a loan but for all
intents and purposes everyone listening
to this I mean yeah there is no such
thing as good debt and by the way
functionally he doesn't even have debt
that's right has the money somewhere
else
yes that's right for a guy like that he
that house could implode and the
insurance company could go look we are
out of business we can't pay you and he
would go oh alright and his life
wouldn't change at all he'd be annoyed
but if you're storefront
it gets evaporated and you didn't have
insurance on it and you still owed that
debt it would crush your life and your
well-being and you would never oh you
would take a long time to recover from
that long time so so three things that
define a minimalist business to me one
is your actions or the actions of the
business align with the values of the
business now if you are a entrepreneur
solopreneur it's probably your values as
well in fact your business's values
shouldn't be different from your own
values or at least appreciably different
so that that's the first thing the
second thing is I think every good
business solves problems and and quite
often people people go the other way
around kind of what you were talking
about earlier is like hey what so we
have a bunch of solutions let's find the
problems yeah and the one solution was
let's take a dollar from people every
month and just silliness yeah and so we
I think every good business or every
good creative even helps people solve
problems and the third thing that
defines a minimalist business for me is
it grows only when it makes sense
I think we're often told that like
unlimited growth we need to grow grow
grow no matter what that that can be
irresponsible I mean that there are
types of bad growth you know a tumor is
a type of bad growth and we don't want
that in our business obviously yeah well
I mean when I think about you know being
a minimalist it's it's you know it's not
about just being a monk and shaving your
head and having nothing I mean it
certainly haven't you know no no and
that's because you know Josh and I we're
not really concerned with the amount of
items that people owned it's more about
our people living deliberately because
we live in such an impulsive society
especially with all the advertisements
we've seen the pressures from society
and success we got to be successful I
mean we have all these things that
really make us not be so deliberate so
with Johnny here you know yet man I
would say if you can avoid debt Johnny
avoid the debt now there are some debts
that are better than others you know
payday loan is gonna be much much worse
than than than a you know a seven year
fixed mortgage I mean they're they're
definitely better better debt there's
better debt to get in than others
so I mean if Johnny has to get into debt
I don't know man what could well how
could we help Johnny reason to get in
debt I mean is there a reason I guess
that maybe that's a better quality was
back to that gallon Dallas right like if
Johnny has to get in debt then maybe
he's lying to himself yeah or it has to
materially affect in a positive way and
this is just my opinion his quality of
life so if he hates that he has to work
part-time and the bottleneck is his
personal time and he would love to run a
brick-and-mortar business and he thinks
that's gonna be great but he would need
a loan to do it that's something to
consider but if he's just going all my
friends say that I should grow this
business and or I feel humiliated having
to work part-time then we're talking
about ego issues definitely not a good
reason to borrow three hundred thousand
dollars from Chase right it reminds me
of this this parable you guys are
probably said there's a thousand times
on the show so stop me if you have
there's this guy this the executive
flies down and there's a guy fishing and
he goes out and fishes and he goes hey
if you just worked a little harder you
instead of just fishing all
you could buy another boat and then you
could buy another boat and then
everybody else could be fishing all day
and you could work a couple years of 80
hour weeks and then you'd own the
company and then you could just retire
and fish all day and the guys like yeah
that's what I'm doing right and I sort
of butchered this parable but the idea
is people work really really really hard
and they're ending up doing the exact
same thing in retirement as they could
do now yeah the difference of course is
if he hates what he's doing now because
there's elements that he could get out
of with a couple years of hard work and
a little bit of debt then yes but if
you're if you're just praying that the
stars align and you don't fail which is
what a lot of brick and mortar food or
restaurant businesses are you're just
rolling the dice and it's it can be
really dangerous because then you have
the debt but then you're working three
part-time jobs and you're doing the farm
cart and you don't get to keep the money
it's going back to chase according to
Forbes I was just reading this recently
in preparation for this there's when 90%
of businesses fail in the first five
years and we hear this similar stat all
the time
and that that is I think both bad news
and good news yes the good news is if
you fail you can move on start something
else the the good news is that a lot of
other people are failing and you can
learn from their lessons as well and so
if you look at people who have I taken
whatever template you know the farmers
market thing or if you wanted to start
at a brick and mortar store you can look
at that template and say what have
people done well what have people done
poorly I remember when I first left the
corporate world I was 30 years old and
it was after 12 years in Telecom and I
managed 150 retail stores oh my gosh
which which I know is really ironic with
the whole minimalism well yeah I mean
this is very minimal absolutely and well
toward the end of it I was when I first
when I first embraced minimalism Ryan
and I were both in the corporate world
working at the same telecom company and
I realized like this in line with the
person I want to be and I just wanted to
go write fiction I had written fiction
throughout my 20s that was the thing I
wanted to do and I had people at work
like when I when I finally decided to
quit I put in several months notice had
a whole transition plan and people came
to me said but were you really going
like they thought I was going to a
competitor or something right because
take me with you yeah and I'm like I
can't I'm just going to go right and
I had set more than one per se you know
if ever if anyone could just quit their
job and be a writer everyone would do it
and I'm like you realize there are some
people who make a living from writing
right hi this isn't the first time this
has ever happens right and but what I
realized is that there is a template
people earn a living from doing what I
wanted to do and I could find several
different recipes tweeze out the
ingredients that work for me learn from
other people's failures and that's
because a lot of people do fail along
the way to success and so maybe we can
talk about some of the the failures that
that you've gone through Jordan and in
the past that have gotten you to the
successes that you have right now yeah I
think every time I think something is
successful then I look back at it later
I'm like well there's a little asterisk
next to it like that didn't quite work
out the way I wanted to and I'm not one
of those everything happens for a reason
type of guys but I am one of those you
can take a lesson from anything type of
guys yeah so when I looked at it makes
it that's a good idea by the way because
it makes it really hard to regret stuff
it makes it really hard to regret stuff
if you focus on the lesson that you get
from things yeah which I know is easier
said than done
cuz this isn't a fortune cookie where
you can just be like oh there's a lesson
and everything good I don't feel bad
about any of my decisions now I mean I
wish that were the case but when I look
back at let's say starting a business
that was focused around dating and
relationships that was not the ideal
business for me to start because I
quickly lost interested in that and what
I was really interested in was human
behavior but starting a vaguely human
behavior related business was not really
something that was gonna work for me but
I my biggest quote-unquote failure is
probably the idea that I went to college
tried to get a job at Best Buy couldn't
really get a computer repair job they
wanted me to sell CDs and I was like
standing next to a life-size cutout of
Britney Spears and you know what
happened to my life after a four-year
degree from the University of Michigan
and then I went to law school because I
thought well the solution of this
problem is more education which speaking
of debt is basically the same thing
going to law school or grad school in
general because you feel like you don't
have enough education and not because
you're interested in the topic is the
worst idea but it makes sense if you
look at our parents
generation because half of them or more
than half pride anyone go to college so
it was like hey if you go to college
you're gonna get a great job well the if
you extrapolate from that if you go to
grad school you're gonna get a better
job than people who just went to college
we're gonna get better jobs than people
who just went to high school now though
the part they don't tell you grad school
at a really top school is probably like
a hundred and fifty thousand dollars for
three years so that speaking of limiting
your freedom I was like I don't even
want to be a lawyer but I'm gonna get
this great legal education and then
towards the end I got job offers from
Wall Street and I was like no way man
I'm gonna do my own thing I might work
for the government because then I can go
travel and do all this cool stuff and
it's like here's what you're gonna get
paid from the government here's where
you're gonna get paid on Wall Street oh
and by the way your level of debt if you
work for the government you're gonna pay
it off in 87 years and if you work for
Wall Street you can pay it off in like
five years and it was like oh cool well
I'm only gonna work on Wall Street as
long as I need to and then you start
doing the math and you're like four
years when you're 27 is a long time yeah
and you keep going and you keep going
and I'm not this is not news for you two
guys from coming from corporate you get
these golden handcuffs and I luckily
avoided this because the economy took a
huge dive yeah but guys that had started
a couple years before me they're working
on Wall Street and they're like oh yeah
well I'm gonna get a boat cuz that boats
are cool and I'm really bored of my job
and I can then go to this boat every
weekend and then they're like well I
should just get a house in the Hamptons
and park my boat there and no and then
I'm gonna get married and have kids and
well my wife doesn't want to take a
lifestyle hit and she's you know she's
taking care the kids so you got these we
call them golden handcuffs because it
looks like your life is awesome but then
if you wake up one day and you go I am
sick of this corporate BS then you go
what wait a minute two mortgages a boat
two kids I've got to take care of my
family and that's if you were
responsible right imagine the guys who
just bought a bunch of shoes like those
guys are totally screwed no assets
remember every time someone in our that
worked with us when they would get a
house or they would get a car like our
boss he would be like yeah
you keep getting buried in debt because
he knew that he could treat that person
worse he could put them through the
wringer because they were beholding to
to that paycheck to pay all the back
payments you're getting over time you're
getting over time the flagship store the
flagship store that you managed at one
point in time in Centerville Ohio I
pulled up once I was at the time I was a
regional manager for like 16 stores and
I pulled up in my Lexus and yeah one of
two and and I pulled up and there were
two Hummers a Corvette and a Mercedes
and these were all front-line retail
employees what I know right now we're
gonna Hummer is like 70 grand yeah
absolutely earth is going on well right
a massive amounts of unsustainable debt
is now going on they're like they're
like I made a few good Commission checks
I can prove that I can afford the debt
payment on this thing this is also at
peak insanity
Peak insanity being like well we can
stretch this to a 63 month turn and you
can afford to pay these you pay for this
Hummer with your retail job as long as
no other emergency ever happens your
life over the next 63 months then you'll
own this Hummer and they do the Munson
because every number after 12 you're
like okay right like that's a year then
you're like ways holy crap but it'll be
a hundred months Yeah right
my kids are gonna be driving this thing
yeah exactly and so the one other stat
that's worth talking about our friend TK
Coleman he's doing these these series
that sort of I against the arguments
hefney calls it the bad college argument
tour he's going out to like colleges and
and like dealing with people's best
objections about why why should you get
into debt to go to college and there are
some you know good objections out there
one is like well the people who on
average people with a as you just said I
people with a degree earn more than
people without a degree which is true on
average but it also conflates causation
with correlation there yeah but the
other thing is I think the stat was 71%
of people
graduate degrees are currently under
employed yeah and so you now you have
$100,000 worth of debt and you're doing
a job that didn't require the degree
that got you into $100,000 worth of debt
it's probably because 99.9% of graduate
schools don't train you for an actual
trade right that stat I obviously made
up but think about this if you have a
PhD in statistics you might go to work
for a firm that does you might become
like an insurance executive or something
like that but probably you're gonna
start off doing something that somebody
who has a BA in English is also doing
and I might you know whatever if I got
that particular subject area wrong fine
replace it with any other graduate
school subject area that's not
engineering Computer Engineering law
medicine or something that readily
prepares you for an actual job so if
you're gonna be a doctor yeah you gotta
borrow some dough but you're going to be
a physician you're going to get
employment somewhere right but if you're
going and you're like I just really love
and trying not to say English but that's
the first one that comes to mind that is
quote unquote useless you're going to
end up with the same job as somebody
else who just has a basic college degree
in almost every case unless you are
really crafty and you and the reason
that we get there is we're told that
well well in order to be successful you
need to go to college and get this
underwater bubble gum chewing degree and
now here's to bubble gum underwater now
you can be a barista right yeah and
that's where we end up and then you
start looking like we're Johnny is right
now and you say okay I'll in order for
me to feel free I need to start my own
thing I need to have I want to do my own
thing because of the jobs that I'm
working it's no it's no longer
fulfilling it's not satisfying and I
guess the last bit of advice I would
have for Johnny is it part of it has to
do with a plan but you've already
figured out what direction you want to
go in now the question is how can you
get there and still make it something
that you love doing a few months ago
around we did a podcast episode with
Paul Johnson from a bank or Canyon City
and one of our favorite musicians and he
actually opened up for us this summer on
tour and one of the things that he did
is he
messed up when he first moved to
Nashville to do music he signed this big
recording contract I started to win like
all these jingles for coca-cola and
stuff and well I mean it was like yeah
he finally made it man like he had you
know someone offering him money he's a
paid musician so that was his goal and
that's the thing that he loved into this
thing that he hated because he was now
because I'll do that yeah
goodsoon your hobby into it people
always like then I can be a professional
XYZ and I'm like oh that's a really good
way to kill your passion yes yeah really
really good way to destroy the thing
that you doing in the world
so maybe the sum it up is I think a
minimalist business never puts money
first but also we have to keep in mind
that money is going to be part of the
equation would be lying for ourselves if
you're running a business saying I don't
need to to make money yeah it doesn't
work that way it's just when it becomes
the primary driver for doing what we do
that's when it kills our creativity it
kills our passion and it kills our life
yeah I really like what you said the
advice you had for Johnny is like ask
himself why he wants to open this up why
does he want to take out this debt and
then Josh to your point about does this
align with the person that he wants to
become so Johnny ask yourself why it is
that you want to grow your business and
does it align with the person that you
want to become what I'll say though I
mean no matter what I mean whether
Johnny takes out debt or not I hope he
can avoid it but regardless as long as
he has as long as he has a plan and as
long as he was working in that plan and
it doesn't go against his values I'm
he's probably on the right track yeah I
think one last tip if I may is do not
quit that part-time job that you have
Johnny until you're the bottleneck in
whatever it is and you can't outsource
anything else because there's this trend
among entrepreneurs now and they're
youtubers and instagramers that are like
quit your job go all-in and I'm like
wait a minute did you follow that advice
first of all probably not secondly why
do that you're burning the ships for
absolutely no reason you're adding a ton
of stress what so you can tell your mom
like look I'm a full-time entrepreneur I
don't even have a regular job now fine
why though right why you're just adding
stress keep that part-time job because
if things go downhill and you hit a slow
season or oh my gosh the suppliers
screwed us over
now the money's gone and we're waiting
for them to refund it but we didn't get
the product you can probably scale up
those part-time hours and survive and
you don't have to worry about it people
go oh I'm quitting my job what are you
doing all day well I have social media
to take care of I've got this to take
care of if you work at Taco Bell and
you're making 15 bucks an hour fine quit
your job do it yourself if you have a
job that's paying you a decent wage and
it's not killing you like literally keep
it and then hire someone else to do that
social media which by the way has like
zero ROI for your business absolutely
and then have them do it and then when
you find that you just can't outsource
anything else anymore because it's the
amount of finite energy that you have to
do whatever it is you specialize in you
know makes sense for you guys not to
have corporate jobs and to do your shows
and to create all the films and all the
the podcasts that you're creating only
you can do that but if you're sitting
there answering all your tweets and it's
taking you four hours a day hey Jordan
to do it yeah he'll do it yeah when we
outsource that years ago I think you
brought up a really good point with the
social media thing our friend Matt the
Avella who directed our documentary of
minimalism that's on Netflix
he he did this 30-day fast recently I've
been telling him for over a year like
that exactly what you just said hey
there's very little ROI and there's
there's there's some value you can gain
from it but if you're looking at it as
the primary driver for your creativity
man that is miss spent time and and I'll
tell you very recently since he walked
away from social media he has been
killing it adding immense value because
he's he's a genius filmmaker and so he's
doing these little five to 10-minute
videos on YouTube and they're all
getting millions of views and and it's
from walking away from this thing and
adding immense value so ultimately
whatever Johnny's gonna do or whatever
it's someone listening this is gonna do
you have to remember that the adding
value to people you minimalist business
is is people focus whether it's your
customers or clients or readers or
viewers or listeners but also the people
you work with and and being people focus
creating outstanding experience for the
people you work with but create an
outstanding quality of whatever you're
producing for the people that you know
you're solving their problems
you guys find that social media has was
bad for you when you were doing it I
mean social media helps spread the
message because I mean you know it turns
out Facebook is where a lot of stuff is
happening so it's a great vehicle to use
for certain aspects of the minimalists
to kind of spread you know our story to
spread our message Twitter is more we
use it for different reasons but I think
that is what we've done with social
media is we will take Twitter will take
Facebook
we're on Instagram and we will use each
vehicle deliberately it's not like we
it's not like we send out a tweet and
then it goes to our Facebook and then it
goes to our Instagram yeah each vehicle
is used for a different reason so I
think it does I mean personally I don't
have a personal Facebook account because
that does nothing for me sure
but as far as the minimalists go I feel
like it does add a lot of value to a lot
of people and it is weighted to kind of
get our word out there I think that so
the beginning of the year we took a step
back and we were doing just that we
realized like the definition of the
sanity is doing you know the same thing
over and over expecting different result
we were doing that we were like posting
everything in triplicate where it was
like well here's our Twitter post let's
repost that on Facebook and re repost it
on Instagram I was dealing that - yeah
and and so at the beginning the year
Jessica who runs our social media and
she's she's really amazing really
talented artists in fact she used to
curate like museums and galleries and
and so she's a curator of things and she
does a really good job of this and so
the beginning a year we literally
deleted all of our social media I went
back to she deleted all the tweets all
the Instagram photo started with a blank
slate and and we came up with a new plan
like we're only gonna use Instagram for
beautiful photos that will add value to
people with like these short captions
that Ryan and I write on Facebook is
great for sharing links and articles
right Twitter is great for sharing only
text we don't share any links or any
photos on Twitter and by creating these
arbitrary restrictions we've been a lot
more creative using those platforms but
using those to augment what we're
already creating they're not the main
creation that makes sense for me I just
found it as a creator it's it sort of
started to drain me especially Instagram
because I was like oh I have to make a
video now oh wait it's over a minute
I've got to rewrite it and I was just
like why am I doing this instead of
making a
show that people actually care about I'm
like trying to figure out how to
shoehorn my creativity into this format
and I agree the format's are important
to get the message out but beyond that I
just didn't want to become an Instagram
influencer I wanted to just do the show
and I found surprisingly YouTube which I
usually hated is actually really fun
like what we're doing right now filming
the show and repurposing it this way and
having people see how we interact that's
been much more fun but trying to figure
out like hey quick speak faster only
we're gonna do this as a selfie and then
give a quick tip it's just it sort of
made me tired by 11 a.m. and I didn't
want to do anything else yeah if you're
trying to force it it's definitely gonna
be it's gonna be tiring I mean yeah the
other thing with social media too is it
can feel like it's productive like you
can feel like you're doing a lot of work
done same thing with the email it's like
you can spend you know six hours making
the perfect Instagram video catching up
on all your emails putting the perfect
tweet out there crafting the perfect
Facebook message but at the end of the
day it's like what did you really get
done yeah guilty of course yeah so he's
gonna do book coming out called digital
minimalism I was wondering if you guys
are gonna jump on that yeah yeah and he
he's I mean we've done a few events with
him in the past and he's like and he's
never been on social media but exactly
what Ryan's talking about here those
things eight the form of productivity so
if I ended the day like I'm exhausted I
did so many tweets and responded to so
many [ __ ] do these likes I got do
you see how many emails list I
unsubscribe from I'm so productive and
that's what it feels like but you're not
actually creating the thing you set out
to create
you